I'm Anderson Acker I work for Wolfram
Alpha a lead developer there I normally
work on food and nutrition but today
I'll be talking about how I explored the
Stack Exchange network sites using
Wolfram language entity stores
I'm Andrew Stein Hawker I'm a lead
developer WolframAlpha I will mostly
work on food and nutrition content on
but today I'm going to be talking about
a data science project that I've been
working on for a while now so anyways
this is about stack exchange exploration
using entities in the Wolfram language I
have a big old wall of text here for my
abstract but that's probably really
boring to read so instead I'll just give
you the outline that's going to be a lot
simpler and easier I'll probably kind of
cruise through some of this because
there's a lot of content here and I'd be
more than happy to have conversations
with people afterwards as well to go
over details and that sort of thing but
basically for anyone who's not familiar
I'll very quickly try and explain the
stack exchange network sites kind of
shows some tools that are available to
explore the data
Ohama as well as a tool that I made to
be able to extract information out of
them and analyze them and then I'll show
some analysis of specific stack exchange
die sites that I've looked at and that
sort of information hopefully will be a
little more exciting than some of the
other stuff I guess as the first thing
how many people in here are familiar
with stack exchange the the network
sites great a lot of people great so I
don't need to spend a lot of time
explaining it for anyone who isn't
though there's a really great tour I'll
just leave the link here for you but
basically anyone not familiar meit's
it's basically a question and answer
site people ask questions people answer
them answers get accepted people vote
them up you know it's you know it's it's
pretty much what you would expect
online it's it's a pretty nice way to do
things so there's you know reputation
points badges and editing and so on
there's a lot of sites that they have
for lots of different types of knowledge
for example probably one of the most
famous ones is Stack Overflow for
programmers mathematics is another
really big one um for you know
mathematics obviously there's also a lot
of other ones for given that this is a
Wolfram technology conference there's a
Mathematica Stack Exchange as well math
overflowed for like research level math
physics and some other you know maybe
less academic things like pets and
travel and that sort of stuff and in
addition to like you know
Mehta sites that are used to maintain
the communities that are there you know
how to answer questions and things like
that
I'm on deal with other moderation type
problems and so Stack Exchange
themselves offers a way to explore their
own data in a broad browser where you
can write sequel queries and that's a
seed or the Stack Exchange data Explorer
and this is a really great thing because
then you can write sequel queries you
know most people know sequel you can
look up things that way but it does have
a few disadvantages to it the queries
are kind of time limited if you're like
me and you don't know sequel that well
it's a little you know daunting to go oh
no now I have to learn sequel and all
these things much better in order to
actually do stuff and they're kind of
time limited and that kind of stuff and
most of it is you know downloading
tables but you can do some interesting
plots as well like this one's a really
great one mostly it's it's fairly simple
this is probably one of the most
impressive ones I've ever seen on here's
this like site activity for Mathematica
not Stack Exchange but it's a lot of
code and I'm not really quick with
sequel that much so so that's that's one
tool it's very simple it's open for
everyone to use straight in web browser
which is nice but if you don't want to
be limited by all that stuff like just
in your web browser are only using
sequel thankfully you've also got
another option too so every couple
months
the Stack Exchange Network has
anonymized dumps of all of their user
contributed content that they put up on
the Internet Archive
there are XML files they're just
compressed down into seven zip files
there's some details there and there's a
nice post on the meta stack exchange for
um what the schema of the files looks
like and that sort of stuff these files
are usually pretty big and kind of hard
to work with and you know it's it's kind
of hard to work with so I built a tool
that converts these archives into
Wolfram language entity stores and
allows you to use entities which
something I'm much more familiar with
ought to be able to use so I won't run
it because it takes a little while but
as an example here you can kind of skip
all this stuff because this is like
boilerplate code mostly the tool is
right here which I've called stack
exchange to entity store and this is
basically a directory which is
conveniently
after the site that I'm have the archive
for which is crafts so people who are
familiar with crafts I figure it might
be easy to understand here and it
produces an entity store and then all
you have to do is register the store and
then now you've got a bunch of types
that are available in entity value to
explore with the way the tools set up is
that there are several ones that are
site-specific so like this one is for is
mentions then you know it's the crafts
Stack Exchange so it's specific to that
site but there are some that are not
specific like VOC types and things like
that that applied to all stack exchanges
as well so that way you can load
multiple of them the details of which
you know we can get into later if
anyone's interested but basically
there's a lot of properties involved
with this so as you might imagine for
users they have about me ease and you
know comments and dates when they
started to created their account down
votes and those kinds of things um it's
all in autumn eyes Dan Dahl um you know
whatever people have you know publicly
put up and stuff like that and posts of
course have similar information so posts
are like questions and answers and a
couple other things that are perhaps
less common um so you can look up things
like you know what is the accepted
answer for a given question is a
question you know accept it as the
answer how many answers there are for a
question you can pull out the body the
plain text or the body you know comments
and those sorts of things so there's a
lot of neat information that's there as
well so the nice thing about this too is
that you can just use entity lists to
list off all the users for example of a
given type you can kind of see here that
unfortunately the yellow boxes don't
form that great for presentation mode
but there is a nice little link attached
to all these so if we just look at a
particular user and you just click on it
it'll take you straight to their actual
page on the site and one of the things I
was really striving to do with this was
to allow you to find the actual original
content as well because you know it's
not really my content here that I'm
trying to show you it's it's really the
content of the site and the users that
actually created it so the goal is to
try and make it as easy as possible to
get you to the original content to
actually see it from there
so we look at a particular user I guess
we'll just look at Tim here I'm on
crafts on we can see
several things one thing that I hooked
up was the approximate reputation
time-series property and basically if
you go through among the history of the
user and their posts and those kinds of
things you can piece together what their
reputation score looks like over time I
made it approximate and called it
approximate because there's some
information like you know multiple site
bonuses and things like that that you
can't really capture with just a single
archive and stuff like that and there's
lots of subtleties that come with that
so it's it's decently close for the most
part some minor things here and there
but you know you can see things like
badges and stuff like that I've tried to
make these these also have links as well
I won't follow it but you can also see
some things like the color like this is
a bronze badge if you're familiar with
the labeling that one's a silver badge
for example and posts also have awesome
formatting that show you know is it a
question or an answer who is the user
who made it short snippet to be able to
see what it is and these also have links
to so for example if I click this one
it'll take you straight to to the actual
page where it is and of course there's
other things like upvotes and things
like that that are also available for
users another property is comments so
you can actually find all the comments
for a user and again these will jump
straight to the contents as well and
won't click any of these in the interest
of time here but you can kind of see
where things go from there and you can
extract my information from those you
can also do stuff with like implicit
entities so for example now we can find
you know posts that have that are tagged
with the watercoloring tag on so it's
pretty easy to do there I've only
grabbed the first five here just to show
it as well the the green check mark here
means that it's actively being used some
of these are historical and you find you
know ones that have been deprecated and
that sort of thing so there's different
icons for those and another nice thing
is that you can use sparkle pretty
heavily with entities to be able to do
much more fancy queries that are a
little more difficult to do with say
entity value on its own so in this case
here I'm using a sparkle property path
to do a somewhat convoluted query we're
given a particular user find all of
their posts that they own they've
created
and then find the comments on those
posts and then find the users that made
those comments and that's what I call a
commenter so these are all of the users
that have commented on posts that this
one particular user owned so it's a
little nested a little convoluted there
but with these symbolic Sparkle queries
it's pretty easy to pull off without
much trouble to sum these analysis that
way going a little further though now we
can finally get into perhaps the cool
stuff more analysis of things that I
found so I was able to analyze the
reputation time series of lots of users
so I just picked the vegetarianism Stack
Exchange because it's a very it's a
reasonably sized one it's not like crazy
huge or anything like that but I found
you know with some Wolfram language
stuff and you can follow this link here
if you're interested in more details but
basically I found the users that have
the most moderate mutation and then I
looked at their time series and gathered
all that up and so you kind of see um
several of them started at the beginning
but you know this user came in later and
sort of picked up the slack um kind of
on that end some other neat things I was
able to do is if we go to travel
frequently mentioned like flight
sequences so airport codes are you know
three or four character long airport
codes I grabbed all 130,000 or so that
we have in Wolfram language and I
aligned them to the airports and
locations and that sort of stuff and I
looked for chains where these airport
codes were connected together with
dashes arrows and those sorts of things
so these are like flight sequences and
then I plotted out the most plotted them
all out here on a on a map so you can
kind of see where these flights occur
which is kind of a neat thing to do that
way going a little further math over
flow I wrote a really big blog post in
like February I think it was I'm on math
overflow net which is also a Stack
Exchange site site even though it does
not have the name Stack Exchange in it
and so there's it's basically for
research level mathematics and so I did
a bunch of stuff to kind of look into
that as well what you're looking at here
and I apologize for the small font here
but I looked at the the fraction of
words that are used on math overflow
compared them to word frequency data in
typical English so this red portion here
if there are points on this side they're
more commonly used in English than they
are on math overflow in this gray areas
between you know this gray area is less
than ten times more likely to be on at
overflow and everything in the white
region is more than ten times as likely
more likely to be on math overflow than
typical English so wait for far over on
the side here is where words that you
pretty much only will find on math
overflow and most of these are you know
mathematician names Wikipedia is very
popular words that you would not use in
typical English you know functors lemmas
you know these are not common English
words as you might imagine so there's a
lot of neat analysis there I encourage
you to look further one thing that's
very common on math overflow is not to
use tech snippets to be able to typeset
math on webpages and so using some of
the Wolfram languages typesetting
capabilities I was able to extract out
lots and lots of tech snippets and I did
a lot of analysis on that this is just
one of the many word clouds I made for
various things this is just integrals
for example it's basically there's way
you can kind of pull those out without
too much trouble and format those and
put them into a word cloud which is kind
of neat going a little further I went I
went as far as even to look at
mathematical propositions that were
mentioned as maybe is you know expected
there so there's a lot of theorems some
conjectures and quite a few less weirder
things axioms hypotheses corollaries and
that kind of stuff that they get
mentioned so it's kind of neat that way
so moving past some of those given that
this is the Wolfram technology
conference naturally it makes sense to
analyze Mathematica dot stack exchange
and there may even be some some users of
it in the room even and if you're
interested in more details on some of
this I have some of it on github so feel
free to take a look on you can even
download the stuff and continue you know
exploring if you'd like I can talk to
anybody afterwards on there's some
decent instructions on there as well and
if you're interested please talk to me
afterwards as well so for example I
scraped all of the code snippets that
are on there and I pulled out the most
common
symbols that are used and this is
without doing any kind of cleaning on it
so you know things like that you would
normally not type out like this like
compound expression and list and things
like that show up very heavily here so
if we kind of get rid of a couple of
those the results are a little more
clean as you can see here you know power
and rule kind of start taking over
there's definitely some more cleanup
that can be done here as well that you
can do from there but it is kind of
interesting to see the wide range of
symbols that are used I'm on I think
this is only the top like 200 or
something like that so you know that you
go deeper and find even more exciting
things I'm not to kind of look at how
which functions are used if you want to
zoom in on particular users you can find
out what the trends are on particular
ones so I've just picked two users here
you can see that this user uses apply a
lot so they probably use a lot of
shorthand notation like double at triple
at and those kinds of shorthand
notations which are kind of neat we'll
talk a little bit more about those in a
little bit and this user uses a lot more
like visualization functions that seems
like because plot range it seems to be
the most common one I can you know high
tens use plot range a lot to plot range
goes to full or all as something I use a
lot to be able to see everything so it's
a very popular option for me as well oh
really
hey there you go yeah he's pretty famous
apparently so so if we go a little bit
further we can look at some other
interesting things and kind of tied this
in to say Wolfram language data kinds of
stuff and so if we look at like version
10 for example version 10 introduced a
wide range of new features one which is
near and dear to me is Association I
really like to use it a lot and so I was
really interested in how often and how
quickly people used it once it was
introduced and so if I look at all the
posts creation dates on I was able to
find out which posts mentioned them so
just by doing some searching and stuff
you can find posts that mention or use
Association you can see that it really
you know takes off right after it's
introduced and it kind of looks like the
community went in waves of you know wow
this is new and then they didn't use it
and I used it and they didn't use it
then you know
leveled out over time so by the time
11:00 came out it was pretty commonplace
it seems like if we zoom in a little
closer we can actually see that even
within the first week or two there were
many posts that were already using them
presumably lots of questions trying to
figure out what it was um maybe
excitement of wow this is really neat
you know I can do some neat stuff with
it there's also some sort of leakage in
the front before it was released but
their's might be a variety of reasons
for that probably I need to robust defy
the code that I'm using here because
these are post creation dates rather
than you know the day they were last you
know modified so some of these may have
been created before version 10 came out
and then later on they added Association
to it that's that's a future thing to
look into but that's that's my guess of
what might be there so moving past
mathematica da stack exchange we can get
into code golf which is something I've
kind of been interested in for anyone
not familiar code golf is the idea where
you want to write a piece of code with
as few characters as possible which
seems kind of ridiculous but it's also a
really neat challenge it's rather
impressive not something that I'm very
good at I've tried it a few times it's
difficult but it is pretty cool to do
keep in mind though that code golf Stock
Exchange comm does not have just code
golf they also have programming puzzles
and those sorts of things where you know
minimizing the the size of your code is
not really um required per se so some of
these results may be a little silly in
some sense but anyways so I analyzed um
the submissions on the site so basically
all of the answers and the vast majority
of them follow the same pattern they
basically have a title that has the
language and then they mentioned the
size and then you know a little bit
lower down they'll have a code block
that has the actual code that's there
and there might be some other
description but almost always that they
follow that format something like I
don't know 80 some odd percent of of
them follow that so from analyzing that
stuff and extracting it all out with
Wolfram language stuff I was able to
pick out what the most common languages
were as you can see here Python and
JavaScript are very popular Wolfram
language is actually fairly common as
well I think it's in eighth place which
is just shy of 3% of all the submissions
looks like so going a little further you
know one thing that you can't really do
on the site is actually
sort all of the things by submission and
so by submission size and so you can
kind of see the format here you know a
language and you know a size and stuff
like that and then I start to put the
actual code in in particularly let's
look at this particular one where you
know if you want to code a snowman
basically make some ASCII art write the
shortest program to do that and they've
got some specifications given a number
you know these are the kinds of hats and
things that you can put on the on the
snowman itself so if we look at those
and we just find posts who have that as
a parent we can pull out the metadata
that I've scraped from all that stuff
and now we can sort them by submission
size which is kind of nice and you can't
really do on the site but now we can do
it here and so a lot of these are like
code golf specific languages and you
know that I'm not really quite so
familiar with or even languages that you
know you might expect to be able to read
or still very unreadable because well
it's it's code golf that's kind of how
it is one of the nice things is is that
you can look at individual code snippets
so like if we look at this Python one
for example we have the snippet the
snippet there we can go and actually run
it directly in the notebook using
external language cells so like if I
evaluate this here ah and then I
evaluate this we can see hey there we
actually got the snowman working so it
actually runs and you can even change
results so that it you know you can see
it run kind of on the fly which is nice
so that's all nice to be able to tie
into other stuff that way and I won't
really go into the code here too much
but you can find out which languages are
used the most for given tags so like for
example primes and math are probably
very common for a Wolfram language as
you can see probably cuz we have a lot
of built-ins that kind of abstract away
a lot of that work again going back to
sparkles stuff you can do some other
neat things so like I was interested in
how languages rank together so with a
simple thing here I was able to gather
all of the threads and the submissions
that go with them and so with a little
bit of processing handling ties and
stuff like that I was able to analyze
some common languages and you can see
that although Python and JavaScript have
quite a few more submissions that's what
this length column is the best position
they're in is still the same and by
median places there all last six place
most of the times so that's pretty good
and their mean is not
- too far off from each other so they
kind of compare you know old firm
language definitely competes with a lot
of these as far as I'm cult kind of
stuff goes it seems some other language
is not so much there's a lot many
reasons for that they're just not as
well suited for writing short amounts of
code it seems of course if we look at
the smallest Wolfram language winners
you know there's some really heavy use
of built-ins and in fixed forms and
those kinds of things which is nice
probably one of my favorites is this one
hash and you may go what is that going
to do well I think the the post here for
this one was to make a reverse Quine so
it basically write some code that prints
itself out but in Reverse and as you can
see it very conveniently how does that
it's a very clever very clever I'm one
thing I thought that was kind of cool
not unsurprisingly I'm on how you can
see that the most common symbols are you
know at and square brackets and stuff
there's a lot more information you can
see on this published cloud notebook the
submission dates and times opposed I
even built a classifier I'm using the
built in classify function so if you
feed it some code golf snippets stuff
it'll tell you what language it is with
surprisingly good accuracy I was pretty
impressed by that even it's technically
interesting but not really I'm that
useful I guess in some sense and and
some other things but I'll let you guys
explore that if you're interested and at
this point I guess I'll stop and I guess
we have a couple minutes for questions I
think thanks
[Applause]